[musique]
La mêlée m'a frappé d'un coup
du lance-grenades principal sous le canon quelque part
mètres de sept
[musique]
c'est très difficile, crois-moi, pas du tout
Je me souviens juste de la première fois où je
s'est retiré du postmorphisme et élève ainsi
Thermodiyala et je regarde, il n'y a pas de jambes
tel
et une telle impression comme si tu connaissais la vie
C'est fini, considérant que je suis toujours seul
c'est une telle bouée de sauvetage et s'en passer
très dur, mais quand même
Je suis là
[musique]
pas du tout parce que je n'ai personne
Je ne suis pas parti depuis les premiers jours
bénévole Eh bien, je savais qu'il y avait un risque
Celui-ci vient juste d'arriver. Eh bien, rien
Pourquoi sommes-nous bouleversés et continuons à vivre
et c'est tout
est parti Alors voilà parti pour le football Mais
tu t'allumeras pour recevoir le ballon que tu
tu utilises le bon nouveau quelque part faux
le côté droit s'étend vers la droite et vers vous
et maintenant tu as besoin de quelque chose comme ça
grouper, ben c'est le genre, pas bien
bien sûr, ce n'est pas comme s'il manquait une jambe à un bras
[musique]